[موسيقى]
من شده اهتمام العربي بالسماء اطلق عليهم
ابناء السماء ان الذي سمك السماء بنى لنا
بيتا دعائمه اعز واطول فلا يوجد امه اهتمت
بتفاصيل السماء ومعالم الارض كحاله الامه
العربيه فهم سكان صحراء ذاتوا اخلاقيات
قاسيه من لا يعرفها لا يتعايش معها
فالذكاء والنباهه والحظ شروط العيش على
ظهرها وعلاقه العرب بالسماء والارض علاقه
ايمانيه قل انظروا ماذا في السماوات
والارض وما تغني الايات والنذر عن قوم لا
يؤمنون وعلاقه استداليه وعلامات وبالنجم
هم يهتدون وحلاقه جماليه ان زينا سماء
الدنيا بزينه الكواكب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومن شده اهتمام العرب بالسماء اسموا
ابنائهم على بعض معالمها فاسموا شهاب
ونهار وفلك وبدريه ومزنه وسحابه وايضا
الثريا والجوزاء انبري مكان البدري انقفل
البدر وقومي مقام شمسي مستاجر الفجر ففيك
من الشمس المنيره ضوءها وليس لها منك
التبسم والثغر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]